hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast that I'm doing on
Saturday so I'm not just checking in on
you
I'm just doing this one now
laying on my back in bed [ __ ] been
sick as a dog
um no it's not covet no it's not monkey
pox
um
it might be scurvy I've been on the road
I don't know what it is but uh
this has just been kicking my [ __ ]
ass for the last couple of days you know
what's hilarious
was
I went into the guest room because I
didn't want to get my wife sick
um slash my podcast studio right
you know right next to the garage and
there's this old ass heater in there and
the [ __ ] thing the heater got stuck
on 80 degrees
and I couldn't shut it off and
I was like it was like I would go to 80
and I would go to turn it down and it
would still say 80 and then it would
show go down to like 71 and then when I
let go of it would go back up to 80. so
I was like What if I go past 80 will
that unfreeze it you know this is my
technical mind here
and go back down so I [ __ ] blew past
it and went up to 90 and then I got
stuck on 90.
so I'm out there by myself
and it's just coming out it's like
there's literally a furnace
just blasting this hell's fire
into this little ass room
next to my garage and I'm out there all
by myself
I'm [ __ ] sick as a dog I'm so excited
to be home and I want to hang out with
my kids and I can't do it because I
don't want to get them sick
I can't hang out with my wife and I'm
just out there now this heat is just
[ __ ]
blasting down
so my wife
is going to bring something out
unfortunately to me
and I said good because the heaters
busted
and she goes out there and I just went
on a [ __ ] nose clogged tirade
about how [ __ ] stupid it is to own a
house because I've every [ __ ]
thing from the front door lock from day
one the front door lock didn't work I
had to replace that all the way out to
my [ __ ] garage every [ __ ] sucking
[ __ ] thing that could [ __ ]
break
I mean everything
every [ __ ] thing the [ __ ]
pipe that lasts a hundred years the
original one that goes out to the
[ __ ]
Town sewer the city sewer that thing
[ __ ] went
and I had to get that thing [ __ ] cost
me I didn't want to tell you how much
that [ __ ] cost me
Charlie Chaplin took shits through that
pipe that's how old that [ __ ] thing
was and these guys came in had to dig up
my driveway to walk under the [ __ ]
house
and um
I just [ __ ] went off
and I was flipping out
Sonia just goes calm down
and I go what do you mean calm down
I I'm [ __ ] what do you mean I'm not
[ __ ] come did she just like she just
walks away now when I'm in that mood
I'm glad she does it she just [ __ ]
walked away she tried to fix it and she
couldn't fix it she did she thought you
know because I suck at technology
you know even like using a thermostat it
used to be just those little things that
you just pushed up and down and that's
what the [ __ ] it was
you know and I've just gotten to this
age now
where I can't [ __ ] do anything
oh my kids are back
I can't do [ __ ] anything right
like I go to a hotel room it takes me
like 20 minutes
to figure like where is the menu
is it on an iPad thing is it on the TV
how do I work this how do I turn on the
[ __ ] TV where the [ __ ] are the lights
I think I talked about this so I was
just coming off the road from that [ __ ]
so I can't get this [ __ ] heat to shut
off
my wife can't get the heat to shut off
and she goes all right I'm I'm gonna go
and I said fine
get out of here right so she [ __ ]
leaves
I apologize the next day right both my
[ __ ] nose was clogged up my head
goddamn [ __ ] Dante's inferno's
blasting down on me
so finally I just [ __ ]
I go on the internet and I'm trying to
figure this [ __ ] thing out I got the
door wide open it's freezing cold out
so now I got this ice cold air coming in
with this [ __ ] hot [ __ ] coming at me
and I'm like I'm literally gonna get
[ __ ] malaria here
um you can't get malaria unless you get
bit by a [ __ ] mosquito there and the
Phil whatever you know what I mean
um
so what I ended up doing
was I I
couldn't figure it out and I finally
just said [ __ ] it
and I went outside I just started
throwing switches I had my little
[ __ ] iPhone I couldn't see [ __ ] with
the flashlight
and I finally found that I just [ __ ]
unplugged it
I unplugged it and it went blue and just
stopped
and then I went back into the [ __ ]
sucking [ __ ] dude it was
literally like I mean you could have
taught a hot yoga class in this [ __ ]
place and then I'm laying there on top
of the covers
and then what was hilarious was then it
slowly
became [ __ ] freezing
but there was a moment
there was like an 11 minute moment where
it was the perfect [ __ ] temperature
that I was trying to get but I feel
Vindicated
because
when the guy came to fix it he did say
that the thing was [ __ ] up
and he took the thermostat thing off so
I don't know
I don't know so I've been sick for I
don't know how many days and I've just
been having like
you know like when the universe is
telling you to just go back home it's a
great thing with this guy
this Indian guy is going like you know
if you're having a bad day just say [ __ ]
it go home try again tomorrow like that
was just playing in a loop on my head
like every [ __ ] thing
that could go wrong like went wrong I
forgot my daughter's thermos when I
dropped her off at school so I raced
back to go get it as my wife is coming
out bring it to me I was looking at her
to make sure she was pulling up I didn't
look and I
I [ __ ] hacked my rim
on the curb I was like ah [ __ ] all right
I'll get that fixed I know a place that
levels it out and paints it oh [ __ ]
whatever right drive down drop that off
come back my son wants to go for a ride
in the old truck
so I say [ __ ] it I'm gonna take him for
a ride
just drive up the hill
you know
a couple streets over I can get up into
the hills where the people have the
views right
um
and uh I go to start it up nothing
I mean not even a noise and I was like
ah you [ __ ] so then I [ __ ]
call AAA and these [ __ ] I haven't
called them in years
and they're like do you want to use a
virtual assistant and I'm like no
you know and then like is this address
your address your home address I'm like
no it's like I'm not giving you all this
[ __ ] information I pay you [ __ ]
money I'll tell you where I'm at
just [ __ ] come over and throw a
[ __ ] battery and eat your [ __ ] right
they were great by the way but that
whole [ __ ] system
we just sent you a text message did you
get it and I did I just said no
I just don't play the game I wish you
guys would stop playing the [ __ ] game
you know
I just say no no no not doing it not
doing it
I want to talk to a person I want you to
send a person I want to talk to the
person and then [ __ ] figure it out
so the guy finally shows up and I'm
thinking the whole time like I literally
could have driven to AutoZone and just
[ __ ] bought a battery
I mean replacing a battery has got to be
other than an air filter the easiest
[ __ ] thing to do
on a car
and that's what I was thinking the whole
time and I'm just like ah you know
whatever so I got a new battery out of
it
so then I handled that and then the one
highlight of my day was I took my uh
I took my son up the hill you know
I go down side streets and then I cross
One Main Street there was nobody there
and I just took him up and uh we were
going up the hill and he's going up the
hill up the hill
at one point we're driving up the hill
you know the truck makes all this noise
it's an old school truck you know and I
looked over at him and he looked at me
and he just ear to ear broke into an
ear-to-ear Grand grin and I was just
like
this is what the [ __ ] it's all about you
know
like he's gonna someday you know when
I'm gone he's gonna my dad used to take
me up that truck and we had a great time
I just like in the moment knew that that
was going to be like one of those things
and I'll tell you I'm teaching both my
kids how to drive that thing you know
how to drive a stick
um
I really believe in that [ __ ] you know
and I [ __ ] hate these goddamn
iPads and stuff like my daughter like
now that you know she has access to one
if you don't let her have one it's like
she's going through a breakup
it's like you shouldn't give a [ __ ]
about
something like this to that level
at your age so anyway
continuing my day
you know even though I'm under the
weather I drop my kid off because you
know it's an important thing to me
driving my kid to school and picking her
up and [ __ ] being there right
so you know we listen to all kinds of
music and stuff like I introduced her to
the Talking Heads
which was so cool right so I always go
deep cut so I went with the party song
swamp
she kind of liked it or whatever but
then I was like she kind of wasn't
feeling it so I went mainstream and
played Burning Down The House now she
loves that song
and she wants me not to sing it she goes
Dad don't sing it I want to listen to it
so
um now she's like requesting it
which is good you know she likes AC DC
you know as far as like my music
Aerosmith
Talking Heads
um Joan Jett
and uh oh Queen
and her favorite Queen song is uh
what the [ __ ] is this song uh spread
your wings and fly away which was like I
wasn't even familiar with that song
I actually downloaded the album
um
just like uh
this past year when Taylor Hawkins
passed away when they were talking about
some of his favorite albums
and I knew that he was a big Queen guy
so he would know the album to get and
this was one of the albums that they
talked about that he liked or whatever
so I was like all right I got to get
past all of the radio Queen [ __ ]
and I like that song and I played it for
so she liked that so all that part of
the day was good so [ __ ] driving home
and I'm coming up and I'm in the middle
Lane and there's like people on either
side it's like three lanes and the
lights green but nobody's going on
either side I'm like what are they doing
are they staring at their phones so I
start to go and all of a sudden this
[ __ ] junkie
walks right in front of my car and I had
to like lock him up
and uh
you know a seat belt
went tight on my you know daughter's
chest and kind of you know crossed her
neck a little bit and she was crying
and she was just like why was that guy
smiling because the guy was kind of
looking at me doing like his Woodstock
dance
as I'm staring at him
you know I mean what are you gonna do
the guy is sick he's literally sick he's
like on drugs so
um
I mean my kids there so I'm not going to
curse them out
and
drive away and she goes oh the seat belt
you know went on my neck I'm like sorry
about that and she goes why was that guy
smiling dad why was he smiling
when you almost hit him I was like
because he's on drugs
she's like what are drugs and I was like
oh God
like all right you know when you spin
around
a lot and you stop and your head feels
like oh I go it's like that
but worse
and you end up being like homeless and
you ruin your life
and she goes and I you know it's
probably too much information she goes
well maybe he was just happy because I
said all right maybe yeah maybe he was
just happy maybe somebody told him a
funny joke or whatever
um I gotta watch that because I kind of
let go
you know
my kid asked me a question I'm gonna
tell him the answer
you know which should get interesting at
some point
but I think it's a huge thing though
some things you should sugarcoat but
like I swear to God
if my kid ever said to me is like
you know is Santa Claus [ __ ]
I'm gonna pause here in case you're
listening with your kids and give you a
chance to hit pause
um if my kid listen to Santa Claus
[ __ ] I'd be like
yeah it's stupid and
I never wanted to [ __ ] get involved
in the lie I don't know why I did
you know
laughs
yeah none of it it's all [ __ ]
I don't know why adults do that to kids
um
and I'm surprised there's not more of
all the things they're trying to go back
and undo
you know
like
just all the [ __ ] that you can do now
that you couldn't do back then
that doesn't make sense to me
talking about Combat Sports and I'll
leave it at that
[Laughter]
and all the things that you used to say
that you can't say that I don't mean any
racist or homophobic stuff I just mean
like nitpick things like you can't use
that expression that expression actually
you know that came out of slavery or uh
the genocide of me it's like I'm like
okay
I thought you guys the other day how
I looked up that uh
that expression keep your shirt on which
was one of my favorite things ever and I
found out like back in the day like the
average working class guy Joe's six-pack
back in the day only had two nice shirts
so if he was going to get into a
physical altercation you took your shirt
off because even if you won the fight it
was going to get all [ __ ] ripped and
so if somebody's getting too heated over
nothing he'd be like hey man you know
keep your shirt off
We're not gonna fight I'm gonna have a
[ __ ] physical fight about this [ __ ]
oh
so then the day continues
um I went into this Superstore
because my daughter wanted to you know
she likes to to uh test out the toys she
says and then tries to get me to buy her
[ __ ] which I don't
and um
I just always goes you know well you
know maybe uh
maybe Santa will get that for you one of
the things she wants is like a little
phone and it's actually hooked up to the
Internet it's like I'm not getting you
that
and neither is air quote Santa Claus
okay I'm not I'm not
she's like why not it's like you know
someday you'll understand
okay
you know when you when you all of a
sudden have meetings that you need to
get to then you can get a phone okay
[Laughter]
uh what do you have a zoom call it a
playground what the [ __ ] am I doing here
so
I go to go out of the superstore
and you know the deal it's all on you
you got to be your own parking
contendant I'm trying to find the
[ __ ] thing and I always lose it
because I was upset with that junkie
walking out in front of my car I didn't
I couldn't find it my wall I finally
find the [ __ ] thing I stink it in the
[ __ ] thing's not accepting it it
finally [ __ ] accepts it then I stick
my credit card in it won't take the
credit card I do it two three times it
won't do it and then furthermore it
won't give me my [ __ ] ticket back
all right so now I'm like well now what
do I do
and it has a little button you know hit
this button to talk to a person
so I hit the [ __ ] button no sound
comes out nothing happens
so now I'm like now what do I do I know
what's going to happen I'm going to end
up getting charged more money it was a
dollar right
so
I go downstairs
I hit the call button it rings and rings
and this guy finally picks up he's like
hello I'm like yeah
I tried to stick my ticket
in the machine upstairs and it ate it it
just took it it wouldn't give me it back
and he goes well you gotta you gotta go
up there and get it I'm like I can't get
it it's in the machine
and he's going all right so you lost
your ticket it's like I didn't lose it I
know where it is it's in that machine
it didn't give me it back and then the
guy's going
all right well what you need to do is
back up and go back I'm saying I'm not
doing that
I'm not doing that he goes all right
then you have to play a lost ticket fee
and I was like oh is that what I have to
do he goes yes I go oh thank you so much
sir I just started being a [ __ ]
because like I had a [ __ ] I'm not
it's not lost
it's not lost it's in that [ __ ]
machine I'm not going to Seinfeld
episode it's not lost
so it cost me 15 bucks
what was so stupid was I charge it
and I take the credit card out and the
[ __ ] Gate's not going up
and I'm thinking like uh I was too
sarcastic to that guy on the other line
so he's just not going to push that
button
and when I ended up realizing was
there was there was a little ticket that
came up
and if I didn't take the [ __ ] ticket
for whatever reason the stupid gate
wouldn't go up you know what's funny
there was a guy in front of me a guy and
he pulled through and there was enough
time if I wanted to to go underneath but
I knew what was going to happen was this
[ __ ] guy was going to stop before he
had to make a right
um and then also I just you know there
was enough trauma with the [ __ ]
junkie out there all right let me read
the advertising here
and um
then I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
uh that's gonna be the end of the
podcast here plus we'll have a bonus
episode I'm just
[ __ ] under the weather here all right
oh look who it is everybody it's simply
safe
you know if you simply say if you know
if you thought about securing your home
with Home Security
thought about having meatballs and
spaghetti with spaghetti and meatballs
what kind of writing is that if you
thought about securing your home with
Home Security
what else would you secure it with but
have been putting it off you'll want to
listen up right now my listeners can
order the number one rated uh Simply
Safe sorry my kid just came in hang on
and hit pause if you want to get the
number one rated
uh Simply Safe home security system 50
off
this is their biggest offer of the year
and you don't want to miss it I got
Simply Safe in my house I [ __ ] love
it all right I'm gonna watch the video
of me [ __ ] walking behind my garage
flipping switches and unplugging [ __ ]
from the other night Simply Safe was
named the best home security system of
2022 by U.S news and world report for
third year in a row in an emergency 24 7
Professional monitoring agents use fast
protect TM technology exclusively from
SimpliSafe to capture the critical
evidence
capture critical evidence and verify the
threat is real so you can get priority
police response Simply Safe is a whole
home security with Advanced sensors for
every room
Window and Door
HD security camera for inside and out
smarter ways to detect motion that alert
you only when the threat is real and
even hazards even Hazard sensors that
detect fires floods
sorry guys and other threats to your
home 24 7 Professional monitoring
service costs under a dollar a day
that's less than half the price of uh
adt's traditional
professionally installed system with the
top rated SimpliSafe app stay in
complete control of your system anytime
anywhere arm or disarm unlocked for a
guest access your cameras or adjust the
systems I don't even use the app that's
amazing
uh don't miss your chance for massive
savings I'm sure I downloaded it though
I already forget the password uh don't
miss your chance for massive savings on
my favorite security system get 50 off
any new system at simplysafe.com today
that's
simplisafe.com
this is our biggest discount of the year
there's no safe like Simply Safe all
right there you go that's the podcast
everybody
I apologize for being a little under the
weather here uh how about those Bruins
12-2 Charlie mcavoy's back got the game
winner against Calgary
we're firing it on all cylinders
so I'm sure somebody's asking already
are they peaking too soon
um I don't know what they're doing but
it's been an absolute joy to watch
um that is it that is all
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and I
will talk to you on Monday
[Music]
Morning podcast from Monday November
10th
2014. how are you how you doing what's
going on
um how was your weekend oh did it go by
too fast
they always do don't they
those [ __ ] days off nothing flies by
like a [ __ ] day off it's unbelievable
why the [ __ ] does it work like that
why shouldn't a day off go by just as
slow
there was any if there's any sort of
like just [ __ ] fairness in the
goddamn world wouldn't a day off go just
as slow
as a work day
you know this you know there's some
Egghead out there well technically it
does double 24 hours shut the [ __ ] up
actually you know what Egghead why don't
you hang out with me on my day off and
then it'll [ __ ] go just as slow as a
Tuesday
it's nothing worse than a Tuesday
you know everybody [ __ ] talks about
Mondays right
like that [ __ ] band where the dude
was banging his own daughter
The Mamas and the Papas where they don't
want to sing that song
rainy days and Mondays always get me
down
you know
what was that Karen Carpenter
sitting there just eating the crust of a
sandwich Karen why oh don't do that bill
don't know it's too too early in the
podcast
all right
don't don't [ __ ] start giving Karen
Carpenter's [ __ ] just because you're
jealous because she's a better drummer
than you could ever be all right Bill
[ __ ] stand down
um no that's all that [ __ ] that old that
whole thing where you know three weeks
of working out is like negated by three
days of bad eating
you know
I don't know what it is like uh
I don't know I've become old frito-face
the last couple of [ __ ] weeks and
it's like I never did a pull-up in my
life
you know so um
I gotta get back on the stick I'm
actually back here uh East Coast last
night I got to do the comics come home
um that was actually I thought it was
going to be a guy in Serena again it was
at the fleet
the TD Bank North gotten [ __ ]
whatever whatever the [ __ ] they call it
where the Bruins and Celtics play that
we actually had the show there I had a
great time I went on last after a bunch
of Beast Comics uh
and uh speaking of Pull-Ups
we were in the bowels of the uh of the
arena and they had like these pull-up
bars which I imagined you know Bruins of
Celtic shoes probably the Bruins Celtics
are too [ __ ] tall to do a pull-up
aren't they
um and I was over there with Lenny Clark
who's like 63 years old and he does
pull-ups and he [ __ ] bangs out like
10 of them it's 63.
Lenny clack right this is what we're
doing before we're going on he just came
off with this [ __ ] lime green pants
the guy's such a character first of all
he's wearing these uh Daddy Warbucks
like loafers with these gold inlays with
these sweatpants and a T-shirt and he's
walking around before the show so I'm
looking at the shoes and I'm going all
right those are definitely his show
shoes there's no way he's wearing the
rest of that [ __ ] on stage and those
shoes are the uh the the big ham and
showbiz
[ __ ] part of the outfit and uh who
would have known
that those shoes were actually going to
be the the muted effect to tether the
whole outfit to to uh some sort of Earth
um
I believe he had on uh
it was hard I can't really tell because
you couldn't look at him for too long
you know without going blind he had on
lime green [ __ ] pants
and uh some sort of blue pink Paisley
shirt tucked in as you do I mean that's
just standard fare when you have on lime
green plants and then he had on his
[ __ ] black slippers with gold inlays
so anyways he's dressed like that I'm
wearing my show shirt we're in the
bottles of the fleet or the TD Bank
North God whatever the [ __ ] they call it
right
um the jobbing.com Center whatever the
[ __ ] they call the thing this year and
they had the pull-up bar
and I was showing them how to increase
the amount of pull-ups that you can do
by doing the negatives you got to do the
negatives dude right two [ __ ] Boston
morons
uh you know going up and then going down
slowly you go down slowly because
usually just let gravity do that well
instead of using your muscles and that
will actually increase your pull-ups
over time if you do that
you know if you do that and then every
once in a while when you go to do your
three sets of pull-ups you bang out your
first set you just go until exhaustion
as many as you can do and even after you
can't bring your chin Over the Bar you
still do reps and just count reps you
know and uh that's the way you go from
12 to 15 15 to 17 and that type of thing
so that's basically what we were doing
while uh we were waiting to go on
and uh Tony V was there
and uh he brought some cigars Marc Maron
was on the show Bobby Kelly was on the
show Jimmy Fallon Jim Gaffigan
uh Dennis Leary hosted
it was just um
it was just it was a veritable hose hoe
um
of the whole scene and uh
I already know I forgot a couple of
[ __ ] guys you had spinning when you
do like a gig that goddamn big
but um
it was just a great time all the Bruins
were there
and uh got to hang out a little bit with
those guys
and uh
what else I don't know it was just my
head's still spinning from being able to
uh perform this [ __ ] unbelievable
really unbelievable
um it was an amazing night Cam Neely
Jesus Christ I knew I'd forget somebody
cam Newley was there it's only his
friggin
benefit and then they had all these guys
like made tapes and stuff
Jon Stewart Conan O'Brien and hilarious
one
um all this you know great time raised a
bunch of money and uh you know I did my
[ __ ] I got my new jokes
you know I pissed a few people off but I
don't know it's just it's [ __ ] weird
it's just where my ACT is right now and
it's one of those things with stand up
where uh
it's not like learning how to play drums
of guitar you can't practice it
you know by yourself and then go out and
go do it you have to try it out in front
of people so you know overall I thought
my set went well went off the rails a
little bit or whatever but uh what are
you gonna do it happens you know every
once in a while you're going to the god
rail there
but uh it was still uh it was still a
great time it's always good to see all
the fellas there and um
I don't know so I can't believe it's 20
it was 20 years
20 years of that [ __ ] thing and uh I
actually this is how old I am
I did the second one
early on I did this I did the second one
which seems like uh
about six years ago but it was actually
18 years ago believe it or not
so they're 19 years into doing it but
it's the 20th one that they did and I
did the second one for all you [ __ ]
Eggheads out there who are going to send
me tweets going actually
um shut the [ __ ] up all right I was 28
when I did the first one and now I'm 46.
it's basically what I'm telling you
um
I don't know it's crazy I can't believe
how much [ __ ] time has gone by uh
patrice's mom was there Georgia of
course it's always nice to see her and
we were all excited about the benefit
we're doing it the third annual Patrice
O'Neal
uh comedy benefit that's coming up in uh
February once again will be at the city
Santa in New York City
um putting together that lineup as we
speak
um
I don't know it's all always a good
thing and of course the always adorable
Jimmy Serpico was there looking as
adorable as ever it's weird most of us
are aging but Jimmy Serpico for some
reason he just keeps getting more
adorable with every year you know
you just want to pick them up and take
them home
I'm just [ __ ] with them anyways
to get Joe yanetti who actually [ __ ]
beat cancer this year
um and he has a terrifying terrifying
story as to how he got it
uh so if you'd like to hear it come out
to uh Saugus tonight I don't know if
he's going to do it I assume he's going
to do it he told the story last night
it's [ __ ] unbelievable well I think
he I don't know if he says how he got it
um I was actually once he started doing
the story I was like I got to get out of
here because if he's going to be going
this level of personal stuff I'm gonna
bomb after him
um
but he told the story of how he got it
so uh if you can't make it to Giggles in
Saugus tonight
um up on Route One
you know diagonally up from the [ __ ]
car loan uh
go see Joey and Eddie live it's
it's a [ __ ] scary story
because if he got it any of us could
potentially get it it's [ __ ] uh
terrifying
and uh speaking of terrifying
I uh my flight from Los Angeles into
Logan Airport
everything's going everything's going
fine
right
we take off from uh LAX
you know when you look down to the left
you see that little [ __ ] barrier
where Marine Del Rey is where Bravo
airspace
is you know the helicopters go 150 feet
off the [ __ ] surface to transition
the Bravo airspace we're [ __ ] up and
over those cuts we bang a left
we're climbing up you know going back
over Hollywood was so high up I can see
over the Hollywood Hills I can see into
the valley
you know I saw UCLA campus then you see
uh LA Coliseum went right over the
[ __ ] Rose Bowl
and then right off into the Mojave
Desert flew right over Vegas I looked
down I saw this stratosphere
right
then you're into Utah you go over the
continental divide the [ __ ] Rocky
Mountains and there we are we're on the
Great Plains
the food supply everybody that's where
they poison it right there from the
Halls of Montezuma God Bless America
right flying right over our food supply
that for some reason
some reason we're letting these [ __ ]
poison it
right
some reason we're going after the
terrorist over there but the [ __ ]
ones in the suits over here it's okay
it's okay
spray the big Casino all over it keep
the bugs off it fantastic I just rinse
it under a faucet you'll be fine
anyways
hey feed that cow some more cow
um
cut the beaks off them
so you fly over that [ __ ] right
then I don't know by then the sun
started going down and everything was
fine
and uh you know I was working on writing
some stuff
and uh shooting the [ __ ] with this guy
and I was telling me he's got this room
he has he's got a garage right with a
room over it which is my dream [ __ ]
house man I always wanted to have an old
house with him to detached garage with a
room over I already told you this [ __ ] I
turned the upstairs into a drum room
slash Cigar Bar slash hooker Lounge
slash sports bar like every man wants
right
um so he basically had that minus the
hookers minus the cigar bar minus the
drums whatever he had this [ __ ] pool
table and all that [ __ ] so we're having
a great time just a good guy shooting
the [ __ ] with he wasn't coughing he
didn't seem like he had Ebola it was a
nice time so all of a sudden we started
our initialists and descended to the
Boston area and um we're out over the
[ __ ] water
you know
and all of a sudden we're just doing
like this circular pattern
I think we went north of the city up by
Newburyport in Marblehead
and we're just doing like this [ __ ]
Circle and we go around and we go around
again and I'm thinking uh this is a
holding pattern this seems really low
and uh the guy comes on he's like yeah
we having a little mechanical issue
we'll try to work it out and it'll be on
the ground shortly but I love that we're
having him we're having a mechanical
problem
uh but we expect to be on the ground
shortly that can be taken two different
ways either we're going to fix it and
I'll be able to land this [ __ ] or it's
going to be a catastrophic failure of
something at which point gravity is
going to take over and land This Plane
for us right
right to somebody's back deck there
um
so
long story short
um
I wasn't even paying attention that's
the weird part
I wasn't nervous at all which was
another weird thing so uh
he comes on the [ __ ] thing and he
would go in for the landing and he said
uh okay we're gonna begin our initial
descent to a final whatever blah blah
Logan Airport uh just to let you know
there's gonna be some emergency vehicles
on the runway there's nothing to be
concerned about this is just standard
procedure it's like what the what's [ __ ]
you mean it's just gonna be nervous
about they brought out the fire trucks I
know what this is for this is in case
we're all covered in jet fuel in eight
minutes and we're on fire
at which point you can't really save any
of us you're just preventing this
airplane from burning down the rest of
the airport as we cartwheel down the
[ __ ] Runway
so anyways long story short there was a
flap that was stuck
um
somebody said it was stuck up but we had
to land faster than normal so I don't
think it was able I don't think it was
moving
you know don't you go flaps down
oh whatever to slow the [ __ ] thing
down when you go to land isn't that what
how these years are flying I believe
that that's what happens
um well whatever we had to land faster
than uh probably what you're supposed to
probably outside the envelope as the
pilots say landed not it didn't even
land that hard
you know and everybody in the back
applauds nobody In First Class applauds
you know because they don't have any
Souls uh including myself you know and
uh so we land and uh we pull over
whatever and it was uh it's pretty
[ __ ] awesome pretty awesome feeling
knowing that the guy was that good
that he basically just
prevented us all from dying I guess they
all do it every time they land it safely
but uh to be able to kind of handle that
I just can't imagine being that pilot up
there
the only like comforting feeling I would
have which you you'd have more concern
for the people in the back than you did
for yourself so you can kind of stay
relaxed
and just be thinking I have to keep my
wits so I don't kill these other people
but other than that what what a
responsibility can you imagine that if I
[ __ ] this up
I'm gonna kill 350 people
you know and then even worse whenever
you know a plane goes down they examine
it if it comes down to being like even
though that was a mechanical
situation you know at some point they
try they put it on the Pilot Insurance
Company see you know what it was
Chucky's fault hey [ __ ] what the
wrong kind of shoes and uh he's pushing
too far right Runner right they'd figure
out something somehow to blame it on the
pilot you know so they can kind of keep
the lawsuits
at a minimum I don't know I I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about so
whatever
um this guy landed us there safely thank
[ __ ] Christ and uh so I've been back
here
in my hometown for the last uh since
Friday and I've been I've been pretty
good I have not uh
I have not hit one of my old uh eating
haunts because I put on a little bit of
[ __ ] weight there as I was sitting in
the writer's room writing F is for
family or pitching jokes as the writers
write it and
um
you know you know the deal I get like
510 outside the [ __ ] Zone and I I
stand in the mirror and I fat shame
myself I give myself a little [ __ ]
halftime speech you know what the [ __ ]
was that today
you know and then I
I can't I get myself
back on the stick so uh
I'm telling you all the [ __ ] that I say
despite the fact I don't know I didn't
know anything about nutrition or I know
very little I'm telling you my tricks
[ __ ] work
when you just can't stop yourself and
you know you've got you want to eat a
large pizza and you [ __ ] know it and
you know you shouldn't you're actually
stepping outside the craving
you know to be like dude what the [ __ ]
are you doing do not shove
that [ __ ] wheel is [ __ ] down your
throat
walk away
all right drop the fork and walk away
right you know it you know what you're
supposed to do but you keep that that
craving that sugar salt [ __ ] craving
it's just having you it's like you're
not even controlling your body you walk
over there that's when you just have to
[ __ ] override it
with common sense in order of [ __ ]
salad
as quickly as possible shove that down
your [ __ ] throat and immediately not
immediately take about five minutes your
levels whatever that is that craving
levels off because you're full
fills you up
and then you look at that pizza and go
what the [ __ ] was I thinking why the
hell would I ever do that so I did that
to myself
I made a game plan before I even left
um I went to the airport and had one
place you could actually get a salad
right and I [ __ ] shoved that down my
throat before I got on the plane and
then I got on the plane and then I was
fine
and I had a banana for the flight shoved
that down my throat I kept pounding the
waters to keep the stomach full and at
one point I had to give in I bought I
got a [ __ ] whiskey and uh and then
that was it I was like all right did a
great [ __ ] job and then all of a
sudden the plane broke and I was like ah
[ __ ] I should have got the Sunday
too late
um keep the drinks coming there
sweetheart
um
but if we ended up [ __ ] Landing
safely and uh I'm back on the stick
landed banged out my [ __ ] hundred
push-ups right
and then next thing you know the next
night I'm doing a gig and before I go on
stage I'm doing pull-ups with Lenny
Clark all right that's the kind of
dedication you have so all you [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there telling me about your
metabolism go [ __ ] yourself all right
you know what you're doing and you know
what you need to be doing all right
you're fat it's not a fatal disease
unless you [ __ ] stay that way
you know I got a buddy of mine right
he's he's a tub of [ __ ] you know and
I've given up on them
I've just given up on him uh because he
went to the doctor and he goes he's just
saying like dude my doctor said uh
genetically my [ __ ] heart is
unbelievable
you know and it's just like all right is
is that all he said
that's all he said oh yeah you don't
have to worry about it you got a great
heart you sure he didn't say hey luckily
you have a good heart but if you
continue to do this
you could have the heart of a Clydesdale
it doesn't matter you're gonna take it
down
you know
Jesus Christ people just go around walk
around you've heard this before
over the age of 60. like how many like
like fat people do you see
I'm not trying to be a dick to anybody
who's overweight okay I'm rooting for
you I'm just giving you some tough love
here you don't see them
you don't see a lot of like
fat people like a fat 70 year old guy
walking around oh that's why all the
Santa Claus is at the mall
or either some young fatty that they put
Rouge on his cheeks to try and like make
him look jolly
you know and then they put some cotton
over this [ __ ] eyebrows
there's a reason why there's not a bunch
of fat old Santa Clauses because they're
dead
right that's what I'm here to tell you
on this podcast Santa Claus died
of a major Cardiac Arrest when he was
58.
playing pickup down at the Y
'all you know
he thought he'd play center and just
post up and thought he'd be fine he
forgot he had to they were playing full
court he had to get back on defense and
that was it
how is it you [ __ ] collapsed right
before he got to the half court line and
right before he passed out you heard the
whistle blow for the backcourt violation
that's a true story
all right and that's why to this day you
have young skinny guys playing now Santa
Claus at the mall see that
there you go and I hate to bring that up
as we we ease in as we begin our initial
descent into the holiday [ __ ] season
oh [ __ ] it's the holiday season Dooby
Dooby Doo
um
so he has a deal you know you're going
to eat like an absolute [ __ ] pig on
Thanksgiving you know you're gonna eat
like an absolute [ __ ] animal in
December
you know it's coming
so why don't you get in [ __ ] great
shape
right before Thanksgiving and just say
listen I'm going to go off the rails on
Thanksgiving
Friday I'm gonna get back on it Saturday
I'll probably have a [ __ ] turkey
sandwich with a little bit of stuffing
in there
and uh maybe some spiked eggnog if I can
[ __ ] handle it and then uh whatever
then you back on it then Sunday you have
a giant [ __ ] salad okay then you go
easy you go easy go into [ __ ]
you're going into December right oh here
come all the holiday parties little wind
shear right you're trying to keep the
[ __ ] level
you know you got to go into these
parties with the game plan
and who's kidding who
if you're eating the way you're eating
and you are a tub of [ __ ] you know
on some level you don't love yourself
you don't
all right and that's how it manifests
itself all right but the only thing
bigger than your own hatred for yourself
is probably you disgust for other people
I'm just using this as a possible
motivational Factor so why don't you go
into that party and look around the
party
and and silently compete with everybody
there and as you're watching other
people just shoving this [ __ ] down your
throat just know that you're gonna win
this game you're going to win this game
tonight right
you're not going to be the one
who's gonna come out
right with a loss on this one I'd be
standing there handing out [ __ ] cakes
to people shoving drinks down their
throat right
be that guy take a couple of parties off
just drink Waters
and just watch what people do and you'll
hear people going oh my God I have to
stop oh my God I have to stop they can't
[ __ ] stop
you know
they're settle in with power right into
that [ __ ] sugar salt
[ __ ] situation right the situation
um that's what you do
oh that's another thing too when you get
to the bar if you can just
order the water first
and you drink that you know
then you're fine
you're fine then your brain's like oh
yeah I'd like some more water and then
you you watch your friends start getting
blurry-eyed that's actually kind of fun
you just stand there watching your
friends like roofie themselves
and you watch them say dumb [ __ ] to each
other that they're gonna have to
apologize for and you walk out of their
squeaky [ __ ] clean
right
you don't want to be fast Eddie
you want to be Minnesota Fats right you
ever watch The Hustler
I mean that one gets all sloppy drunk
and Jackie Gleason you know takes out
the [ __ ] towel freshens himself up
throws his jacket on and [ __ ] kicks
Paul Newman's ass that's the guy you
want to be walking out of the Christmas
party then you but you pick one
you pick one [ __ ] Christmas party
where you're gonna throw down you got to
have some sort of fun well you're just
going to get absolutely [ __ ]
obliterated all right
and that's the one your boss isn't there
you know
that skank you want to [ __ ] isn't there
all the [ __ ] Temptations aren't there
it's just you and the booze staring each
other down like one of those [ __ ] UFC
posters
right
UFC 2006 the Abomination whatever the
[ __ ] they're out of [ __ ] adjectives
for those things but I'm still ordering
all of them because I love it right
just you and we are your favorite drink
some of your friends with the game and a
little [ __ ] Christmas tree right
whatever a couple of prostitutes dressed
up like [ __ ] Santa's girls which she
never really had if you really watched
those specials you know but everybody
has their own version you gotta respect
all religions
you know
get yourself a couple of [ __ ] running
around you know to give you drinks
you know
creating this [ __ ] Utopia
and uh that's the one you just get
[ __ ] blind drunk
and you just celebrate the baby Jesus
the way it was meant to be
that's how you do it
then the next day you write [ __ ] back
on it you're right back on it and then
you join me at the [ __ ] Rose Bowl and
watch me get blind drunk and then that's
it that's you you pick your spots
picky spots and you give it a little
face wash and then you'll be fine
you know is it me or do I sound more out
of my mind this week than than most
weeks
I'm not sure you know what it is right
now it's football Sunday
it's the middle of the afternoon uh the
first game
of the week is on
uh the one o'clock games basically back
here east coast and why aren't I
watching why could I give a [ __ ] because
the Patriots aren't playing today
I hate the [ __ ] bye week
I hate it it's like all it's like that
feeling when your team gets knocked out
of the playoffs and all of a sudden it's
like [ __ ]
now what do I got to do
all of a sudden it's just like yeah yeah
we're just going to give you an
experience of the off season during the
season just give you that little foot
make your heart skip a goddamn beat so I
don't know what to do with myself I want
to watch that four o'clock game
um
Seahawks versus the Giants I always like
you know I like the I like the defensive
teams
um
and I'm also interested to see I want to
see Eli even on you know Seahawks
haven't been as good as they were last
year as always happens you know you went
deep into the playoffs you won the
[ __ ] Super Bowl
uh you know Pat Riley the disease of
more that I learned through the Bill
Simmons book
um
people leave try to get more money every
coach thinks they're a [ __ ] head
coach all that [ __ ] happens but
still the the core of the team is there
and um I love watching Eli play against
Great teams because he always has big
games so uh but it is a regular season
so who knows how he'll he'll perform but
I'm looking forward to that one so
that's the game I'm gonna watch
If You Give a [ __ ]
um at which point it already happened
right so why am I talking about it well
because I got to fill up an hour
basically oh my apologies last week I
guess the uh judging from the 2000
emails I got and tweets the volume was a
little low last week um I apologize
we're still working out the niches on
the um
or the glitches I should say on the new
uh the news all things comedy
um podcast Studio
which we hope to be a fully functional
soon obviously this week I'm back in
Boston so I won't be using it but next
week I'll be right back in there
um so anyways what went on this week in
the wild
what went on the world that went on in
the world [ __ ] Phil Rudd drummer of
AC DC
gets arrested for allegedly trying to
hire a guy to murder two people and they
found meth in his house
you know Phil Rudd's one of my favorite
drummers of all time in my favorite band
of all time
and I gotta tell you
for the [ __ ] life of me
all right
who the [ __ ] starts doing meth at 60
years of age all right I hate to
criticize the guy I love the guy
love the guy to death but what the [ __ ]
meth
I mean still doing blow at 60. what the
[ __ ] that does to your heart man it's
unreal and if you saw his pictures he
didn't even look like himself and he
actually looked like he was missing some
teeth like this [ __ ] guy was doing
meth
at least he looked like it he looked
like those Billboards you see when you
drive through the Midwest
not like Chicago not Ohio you get into
the Midwest
that Slipknot country right
that uh you know uh uh of different
factions of the clan marching down the
street part part of the [ __ ] the the
upper Pacific
Northwest right Montana
Idaho Wyoming
the Badlands of The Dakotas right that
[ __ ] level of Meth
um
but the charges have been dropped he's
still being charged with meth
and uh but at least they dropped the um
the other [ __ ] so as far as I can
tell I think they're still going to tour
on this album with them
um but if they don't what do you think
they would do
you think they go back to Simon Wright
or Chris Slade
I know Chris Slade openly is discussed
he did not like how he exited the band
I don't know that they according to him
I don't think they called him
they basically had Phil run the band
they had a dust up
Phil Rudd and Malcolm so much I know
about this [ __ ] band I actually know
the true story but I'm not going to say
it
why not bill because I'm not a dick well
I am a dick because I brought it up
I talked to a drummer in another band
and he actually talked to Phil Rudd and
he told the [ __ ] story why the [ __ ]
he he got kicked out and uh you know
it's one of those old stories
that's whatever he gets kicked out they
get this guy Simon Wright 20 years old
next thing you know he goes from [ __ ]
playing the local bands the next thing
you know he's in Simon Wright quits AC
DC to join Dio
right I guess he was sick of playing the
4-4 [ __ ] he wanted to do something else
so he leaves then they get Chris laid
and after nine [ __ ] years they decide
they want to go back to Phil Rudd
according to Chris Slade
um without him knowing he was out of the
he found out he was out of the band when
the band sent out a pre press release
that he was no longer in the band and
that they had gotten back together with
uh Phil Rudd with
you know if it went down like that then
uh you know
I'm sure when uh Chris Slade hears Dirty
Deeds he probably has a different
[ __ ] view of it
now than other people oh Jesus Bill did
you really have to do that [ __ ] old
joke well you know it's a long podcast
what do you want from me so anyways nice
to hear that Phil Rudd is no longer
being charged with uh hiring trying to
hire [ __ ] travolting
Sam uh Jackson's [ __ ] characters in
Pulp Fiction he's clear to that now now
it's just meth now he's just another
[ __ ] guy on meth
60 years of age come on Phil
you know it's funny when I first read it
somebody sent me a text said Phil Rudd
and I I immediately thought
uh
immediately thought Paul Rudd
and I was going like how the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] would that guy want to have
killed
he's a nice guy he's a family man what
the [ __ ] like that one really blew my
mind that was Phil Rudd
and it still kind of blew my mind but I
still kind of understood it
you know those rock stars right
you get a couple hit albums under your
belt next thing you know you got a
pistol and a big bag of coke you know
you don't know what you're saying
anymore
right you pouring vodka in your mouth in
a swimming pool while they film it
um
anyways oh good news I I have teased the
people
down under
Australia New Zealand and I have [ __ ]
threatened that I was going to be doing
a tour down there it is coming together
the dates are together it's going to be
the end of January beginning of February
right now it is a 10-day tour
that's kind of went close
uh two cities in New Zealand
all those [ __ ] uh Australian one
Perth Brisbane however the [ __ ] you say
it Melbourne
Sydney
uh I don't know what else I got in there
and then we're also trying to possibly
tie an Asian run in there
where I might believe it or not do India
we just have to see if there's any sort
of interest there I mean I know I won't
make any [ __ ] money but why wouldn't
you go to India
you know Christ I'm talking to those
people every day on the [ __ ] phone
anyways anytime I get into some
automated thing right be nice to talk to
some of the people on the other end of
that phone
um
I know this woman that books Singapore
but I'm afraid to go there after that
caning video
and considering
spitting gum out on the sidewalk is
illegal
um I I don't know how they would react
to my act like how many [ __ ] lashes
that would be but I'm not into being you
know having my butt cheeks having
muscle spasms as I'm waiting for the
next height
[Laughter]
would I be
is [ __ ] German Irish and pasty as I
am oh my God after that first lash and
it would look like a [ __ ] face is a
death video
holy [ __ ] so anyways I'm really really
looking forward
to going over there speaking of AC DC uh
Bond Scott rest his soul his final
resting place is in Perth so I'll
definitely have to make a trip to that
um
and then other than that you know I just
I'm excited to go uh over there and uh
you know watch my step Don't Step on any
of those [ __ ] brutally poisonous
snakes they have
we're actually trying to figure out how
to do the tour right now because from LA
to Sydney is a 14-hour flight and if you
ever do it what you want to do is don't
you see is take the 4 P.M flight
all right you get on the plane you have
a [ __ ] meal no you watch a movie then
they bring you a meal then you watch
another movie you just killed four hours
then you go to sleep eight hours later
there's your 14 [ __ ] that's 12 hours
right whatever give or take basically
you wake up you're almost on Final
Approach it's the it's the best flying
back sucks I don't know what to do I
don't know what to tell you other than
they get blind [ __ ] drunk and take a
[ __ ] horse tranquilizer you're just
gonna have to kind of sit there and take
it
and keep looking at your window hour
after hour realizing you're over a place
where there's nowhere to land
um
so anyways but
so you fly 14 [ __ ] hours from LA to
get to Sydney and then Sydney to Perth
is basically like flying across the
continental United States
I want to say it might be a little bit
shorter
but who the [ __ ] wants to do that but
my guy's saying What If you flew to
Melbourne stayed there for a day
got a good night's sleep and then got up
the next [ __ ] day and then fly I'm
thinking just get it over with
just [ __ ] get it over with I don't
know how we're gonna do it but uh the
good thing is once you're there you're
there
and um I don't fight jet lag
initially
you know you got to stay up you got to
stay up [ __ ] that no you don't go to
sleep
go to sleep you wake up at [ __ ] 11
o'clock at night like at seven in the
morning and you just go on YouTube and
you watch old Super Bowls
and uh you'll find a casino there'll be
something to do right
um but anyways I'm really looking
forward to doing that and then also
later on in 2015 I'm going to be doing
an Eastern European tour possibly maybe
touring all of Europe and um
so the way I'm going to try to do it is
I'm breaking up my tours over a two-year
period I'm figuring out this strategy
uh and the tours are Eastern Europe
Western Europe
Australia uh Asia
and then
Canada and then I always have uh the
United States is an ongoing thing
so I just sort of when I'm not touring
the states I'll just break off and do
like a 10-day tour of one of those
um and I've always been putting out my
special on Netflix and as Netflix has
grown and they've gone worldwide I keep
getting more people that know who the
[ __ ] I am and I keep expanding it and
the great thing about that is
as I you know as the dollar collapses I
have all these different other [ __ ]
places
or I can maybe earn money in their
currency and I can come back here and
buy a pelt to put over my junk
you know because there's no way I'd ever
leave this country you know
I just [ __ ] would survive it
um so anyways
and plus
as I increase you know people liking
what the [ __ ] I do I got this cartoon
coming out I know I'm hyping it 13
months early F is for family
uh we wrote another killer [ __ ]
episode
I cannot wait for this thing I cannot
[ __ ] like no thing I've ever done
I cannot wait for you guys to [ __ ]
see this thing and I know I'm an [ __ ]
for bringing it up this early
but uh it is the most [ __ ] fun I've
ever had doing it Netflix has been
unbelievable
uh they're actually saying push it
further push it further push it further
they've been ridiculous
um
they've been unbelievable to work with
and uh
you know and just the people that I'm
I'm writing the thing with and
everything is is uh as I say they're
right and I just sit in a writer's room
and I pitch my jokes but um
I can't [ __ ] wait for this thing to
come out you know and even if we only
get to do six
uh I swear to God when I'm 80 I'll be
talking about how much [ __ ] fun I had
doing it and that's that is no joke
um so anyways
what do we got here let me see if he
sent me the [ __ ] advertisement you
had me killing time here
oh gotta love the Bruins app right here
up to the minute [ __ ] do you guys
have you guys have like the uh the apps
of your favorite teams I love when they
do that I have this one in the NHL one
tells me about all the trades everything
that's going on
this is not a commercial by the way
defenseman David wasovski sustained a
groin injury and will be out two to four
weeks
you see that now I can get on with my
[ __ ] life
well you know it was one of the coolest
things I got to do last night
and I'm gonna have a YouTube link to
this I got to talk to Adam McQuade and I
remember one of my favorite things
moments of the Bruins over the last few
years other than them winning the
Stanley Cup
and um and always Bruins Canadians games
are always [ __ ] great win or lose
they're always [ __ ] awesome to watch
um was I remember we played the uh the
Phoenix Coyotes and uh Rafi Torres uh
you know dirty play
[ __ ] sh his elbow or shoulder into uh
farence right in his jaw and
McQuaid immediately
as the dude was throwing the elbow or or
the [ __ ]
shoulder his gloves were already on the
ice and he beat the [ __ ] out of the guy
it was just textbook
how to stick up for your teammate in
hockey and um once again you know I was
uh well I'll have a link to that fight
if I could find it um
and once again I was I was talking to uh
we talking about hockey on the way over
to the Garden uh the other night you
still can't [ __ ] believe I got to
perform there
and um
you know we were talking about I was
saying how you know that was that bench
clearing brawl that I told you guys
about a long time ago I went to the game
um I'll put that link up too I was at
the old Boston Garden it was the Chris
nylon game when he took the butt end of
his stick and knocked millbury's teeth
out and then he got kicked out when he
walked by the Bruins bench Ken lindsman
pushed him he he pushed Kent lemons
linsman that's right because lindsman
you know said something and then linsman
chased him down the hall like he was
actually going to fight him
and then because he knew all the Bruins
are going to follow him next you know
Canadians bench empties there's a fight
on the ice that's fighting off the ice
there's cops involved and all this [ __ ]
and someone's going like I love how like
these are the Great Moments in hockey
right and it's like ah Jesus Christ you
[ __ ] non-watching hockey [ __ ]
there's all the goals and all that [ __ ]
you know
those are also great but the fighting is
all I don't understand why people have
such a [ __ ] issue with fighting in
hockey we got to get the fighting out of
hockey do we have to get the fighting
out of boxing we have to get the
fighting out of the UFC if fighting is
so [ __ ] bad how can you have a
[ __ ] sport that that's what the sport
is oh it's barbaric okay but if that's
what you're trained to do then it's the
sweet science
you're a mixed martial artist but if you
do it on hockey skates you're a [ __ ]
animal
I don't understand it
I don't it's a part of the [ __ ] game
now Jesus Christ is with the phone
I'm at my parents house let's see how
long theirs goes that's toe
there's somebody downstairs right
come on somebody pick it up for [ __ ]
sakes for me for the podcast for my own
sanity
there you go somebody got it all right
so um
anyway I just don't understand what the
[ __ ] problem is
I don't get how people we got to get the
fighting out of it we got to get it it's
like dude you don't watch hockey you
don't have to do anything
just don't watch it
you know what I mean
do I sit there going we got to get the
layups out of the WNBA there needs to be
more dunking
give a [ __ ] play the game while you play
it
I don't I I feel [ __ ] I it drives me
nuts [ __ ] drives me nuts whatever so
I'll have I'll post that bench clearing
brawl I'll also post
um
the uh
Adam McQuaid fight and then for all you
[ __ ] hockey purists that don't that
just want to see goal scoring and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I like
Olympic hockey yeah I like curling too
um
I'll I'll post the uh whatever the
whatever that [ __ ] and get new kid's
name is there on St Louis
Vladimir uh [ __ ]
Tarantino whatever the [ __ ] his name is
let me see
where the hell is it I [ __ ] tweeted
about him
I said the moves he was making me were
making reminded me of some of the moves
I used to do in the late 90s during my
rollerblading days and then of course I
got a bunch of [ __ ] for rollerblading
you know last I remember rollerblading
that was a a phenomenon that swept the
nation
you know
am I wrong
am I wrong thinking that
uh Terence senko Vladimir Tarasenko all
right for all you people out there who
want to get the fighting uh just know
that this is also still happening and
that uh goaltending in the league is uh
post Patrick Wah is is become an
entirely different art in itself if you
watch old
hockey uh highlights and you watch those
old stand-up
[ __ ] goalies you understand why
[ __ ]
actually I still can't believe it was so
difficult to score 50 goals watching
stand-up goalies they [ __ ] just you'd
come in and skate you'd shoot the puck
and they'd either kick out their their
right leg or their left leg pretty much
straight out
um the stand-up goalies and then once
Patrick Wall came in the butterfly that
was over
like a Jimi Hendrix Moment Like guitar
was never the same goaltending was never
the [ __ ] same after that guy
and um
I don't know whatever I'm probably
talking too much [ __ ] hockey here
there's like eight listeners going no
if you want to hear more hockey talking
what you want to do is go listen to Joe
bartnick's Puck off Rose Bowl
tailgate Legend Joe bartnick
all right sponsored by Crown Royal
I don't even know if it is uh the puck
off podcast you might want to check that
out so um I think at this point I've
talked myself out I'm gonna wait for the
uh
wasn't I supposed to look for that I
keep pushing the wrong goddamn buttons
you know I got one of these little
[ __ ] iPads with the keyboard
you know and I thought I was really
smart and like and you know I hooked the
[ __ ] I synced up the the keyboard
with the iPad I didn't know you had to
charge the [ __ ] iPad uh the the
keyboard too right you know what [ __ ]
kills me the one that [ __ ] charges
the [ __ ] I the iPad itself you need a
different plug for the [ __ ] keyboard
these these
[ __ ] Steve Job [ __ ] it's like how
much [ __ ] money do you nerds need to
[ __ ] make
I don't know all right let's do some
advertising for this week all right all
right here we go DraftKings everybody
millionaires I'm mate all season long at
draftkings.com America's favorite one
week fantasy football site oh today one
fantastic one fantasy means no season
long commitments play whenever you want
got an injured player no problem at
draftkings.com it's like a new season
every week so you're never stuck with
this same place all right pick your team
in minutes everybody and you could be on
your way to winning huge cash not that
little cash huge cash this season one
listener turn 10 bucks into five grand
another turn two dollars into ten Grand
and a new millionaire has been crowned
nearly every week this season at
draftkings.com you could be next Imagine
winning a million dollars in one day
just playing fantasy football at
draftkings.com call to action get free
entry into their hundred thousand dollar
fantasy football contest this weekend
where first place takes home 10 grand
head to DraftKings draftkings.com now
and enter the promo code defense d e f e
n s e
oh you [ __ ] morons that spell it with
a c it's with an S to play for free
draftkings.com bigger events bigger
winnings bigger millionaires enter
defense
with an s
for for free entry
did I actually I think I misspelled it
making fun of you guys uh for free entry
now at draftkings.com draftkings.com
that is draftkings.com all right
stamps.com everyone
you know the deal mailing your letters
and packages has gotten a lot easier
thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you
can mail and ship anything anywhere
using just your computer and your
printer no more trips to the post office
everybody and it's so easy anyone can do
it just click and print and mail that's
it with stamps.com buy and print
official US postage right from your own
damn desk staff.com does all your work
for you stamps.com even gives you a
digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage for any
letter any package any class of mail and
sets and setup is easy to do in minutes
you'll be printing your own postage your
very own postage you'll never have to go
to the post office again I use
stamps.com to send out all my posters or
whatever crap I'm selling at the end of
my shows I am a [ __ ] if I can figure
out how to do it well doggone it so can
you right now get this special offer
when you use my last name Burr b-u-r-r
no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer which
includes a digital scale and up to 55
free post do not wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and you type in Burr b-u-r-r that's
stamps.com enter Burr
there you go that's it that was an easy
week everybody only two reads I think
I've insulted all my other uh
advertisers you know they're not always
so Keen with some of my reads over here
so you know what can I do
what can I do what am I looking for I'm
trying to figure out how far into this
podcast I am 48 minutes Jesus Christ all
right you know last week when I was
stretching for time I was so out of
sorts being in that studio I forgot to
actually uh
I forgot to read the damn questions from
last week so anyways let's see here here
we go here we go
um oh by the way my Yoko Ono Chuck
barrier Berry video broke a hundred
million views
um
let's see here and people have been
sending me the following Yoko covering
Katy Perry's Firework
uh man I don't want a trash Yoko I
actually think our band's good I just
[ __ ] I I more when I was doing that I
really I was really insulting John
Lennon
you know
one of the great musicians of all time
so who the [ __ ] am I to do that you know
what are you gonna do
this [ __ ] annoys me just seeing some
guy just afraid
I mean do you like seeing do you like
seeing a woman being just dominated by
some guy and she's too afraid to open a
[ __ ] mouth it's it's horrific to see
it it works both ways
you know what it is you just wish that
the [ __ ] two psychos would get
together but it doesn't work that way
you know what I mean two selfish [ __ ]
can never be together because they're
selfish [ __ ] what they have to do is
they go out and they find big-hearted
forgiving people
that look the other way when you grab a
microphone and go yeah yeah yeah in the
middle of a [ __ ] song
that's not even exaggeration that's
actually almost a dead on
impression affection Daryl Hammond would
probably be like wow bill that was
really good did you listen to audio of
Yoko Ono as you drove around in your car
and I'd be like no Daryl you know what I
just naturally had that one
um you like that you like when I invent
compliments from legendary comedians um
all right last alimony payment dance guy
Bill a million people have probably
already sent you this or maybe you saw
it yourself on bar stool yeah I watched
it I'm always on Barstool uh Boston
Barstool by the way um I'm always on
that thing they always have great videos
um you know some of some of the the
[ __ ] people on there they're so Pro
Boston Sports you know what I mean
that it gets you know I'm one of those
guys that if we have a piece of [ __ ] on
our [ __ ] team and you say he's a
piece of [ __ ] I'm not gonna defend him
you know what I mean which then gives me
license to trash you a piece of [ __ ] and
then you say yeah yeah you know what you
know what you're right
we got a piece of [ __ ] in our team too
and then we get to drink together
there's no fights there's no lawsuits
there's no broken teeth it's it's
wonderful it's one of the great things
about being an old guy is you see the
middle ground but having said that I
still love my Boston teams and uh
I I love that sight I love that site so
anyways I mean uh the video is the
greatest thing I've ever seen it's
Thursday morning at my shitty office job
and I swear my feet started bouncing
under my desk in pure joy for this man
uh love you and love Nia go [ __ ]
yourself yeah it's a great video we'll
post it this guy
this guy is making his final alimony
payment
and he says how much it is it's
something like just under 10 grand this
guy's been given some woman
almost every [ __ ] month
now granted this guy might have [ __ ]
up his own marriage he might have [ __ ]
around on her or whatever but just Jesus
Christ to have to give
another human being 10 grand a month
for [ __ ] years
and you did not maim them
you didn't cause them
an inability to go out and get a [ __ ]
job and earn a living is J it's [ __ ]
Criminal
and this isn't child support people this
is alimony
you're giving somebody 10 grand of
[ __ ] it's just unbelievable so this
guy is making
his last payment and he's doing this
[ __ ] dance
it's one of the happiest guys
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life it's
[ __ ] hilarious and um
I do have
hope that in the future
when this late is pushed by women is
over
you know it's kind of like a game
between the two of us right so right now
it's it's hardcore women
everything bad that ever [ __ ]
happened between men and women it's
going one way right now it's just guys
need to grow up right we got to stop
talking to them on the street
you know no more uh she was asking for
it
uh what else what else are they telling
us
um you know we gotta listen more we need
to cook more we need to do a lot of
their [ __ ] jobs around the house that
they don't want to [ __ ] do because
they have a job now
you know it's like well so do I so I got
to do the job and all the housework is
that we [ __ ] saying no I'll pitch in
now you won't you'll start to do it and
then you'll come home you say you're
tired and then your bottom lip starts
quivering then I feel like a bully and
next thing you know I'm wearing a
[ __ ] apron
um
but I think eventually
um unless my conspiracy theory is true
uh
my conspiracy theory is basically this
well let's finish the first thing
eventually at some point there's going
to be a pushback
by men about these divorce settlements
to try to get them a little more
not as [ __ ] crazy
okay
um
because I mean I just I don't just the
amount of [ __ ] money and that she's
used to a certain lifestyle I mean
whoever came up with that was a [ __ ]
genius
I mean how they got the I'm used to a
certain lifestyle yeah the lifestyle you
had when you were together this
relationship failed
all right so yeah
you you don't have that lifestyle
anymore and neither does he
why does one person or or
whoever's making more money to be fair
to women in this stuff because I know uh
who the [ __ ] because Nia's always
bringing up the women who are getting
[ __ ] in this thing because you know me
I'm so [ __ ] one-sided and ignorant
um
who got [ __ ] over I I can't remember
who was she saying Halle Berry
one of those people just has like some
ridiculous payment that they had once
again they just they were in the state
of California they were making way more
[ __ ] money and now the person that
they used to be with gets to act like
you know
they you know I don't know what they're
they're [ __ ] crippled they can't go
out and get a [ __ ] job too these
people do you realize that there's
people paralyzed from the [ __ ] neck
down who have written [ __ ] scripts
for movies that got made
you know what I mean you're sitting
there with all your [ __ ] faculties
and you want 10 grand a month you lazy
sack of [ __ ] it's [ __ ] unbelievable
unfucking oh man you know what there's a
there's a there's an article
do I have you know I'm gonna get up I
gotta I gotta get this thing right now
hang on a second oh I got an article I
gotta show you
yeah I read it on the plane
it's a uh
it's in a Maxim magazine
which who's kitten who Maxim magazine is
basically a jerk-off magazine for
somebody
either who's still living at home with
their parents and doesn't want to get
caught looking at porn or they plan on
running for political office and that
they know there's no way to get it
traced back this is probably actually
the purest pornography that you could
actually look at
I'm being an [ __ ] it's not that bad
but it's one of those things where
maximum magazine a lot of times there's
articles in there that I want to read
about but the woman on the cover it
always makes me feel like a piece of
[ __ ] buying it like look at her tits huh
you know um but this one actually on the
cover it said uh Hot Wheels of course it
said I'd say Hot Wheels it's got some
you know
gorgeous [ __ ] woman with their
[ __ ] tanned up titties hanging out
and it's 2014's fastest muscle cars
sexiest supercars and the ultimate
Jaguar right so I'm like all right I'm
getting on a plane I love [ __ ] cars I
want to read about this [ __ ] I'm a car
guy I got a Prius right
[ __ ] Catholic guilt go [ __ ] buy
yourself something you freckled [ __ ]
um
so whatever so they got the usual layout
here right and they got this beautiful
[ __ ] car this is how old I am so they
got this [ __ ] 20-something model
laying on her back on the [ __ ] hood
and I'm actually annoyed by her like
would you get off the [ __ ] car so I
can see it how [ __ ] old am I at this
point I got it when you [ __ ] that's the
position you'd be in if I was banging
you you're not gonna [ __ ] me get out of
the way of the car
um but they're actually just doing the
background on the on the model so they
actually I didn't understand the layout
of the magazine and you know what she is
gorgeous she deserves to be laying on
that car
um
but I imagine well you know a lot of
women would be offended by it because
you know what does it really
what they're really saying in this
magazine is you get this car you get
this woman
you know none of these photos does in
any way shape or form does it show that
this woman could possibly own this car
despite the fact that she's a model in a
major magazine you know she has a nice
car but the way they photograph her is
this is the position I had to lay in
just to get a [ __ ] ride in this
goddamn thing although one of the photos
she she is carrying a helmet
but that's probably just for safety
um anyways so I'm reading through all
this [ __ ] and I come to this this
article and it's uh
you know me totally misjudging this
magazine where I'm looking at it like uh
like I live in [ __ ] Utah
where the [ __ ] is it God damn it bill
you had it you had the [ __ ] article
and you went off on a damn tangent
uh
um
who the [ __ ] is it
was about this Formula One car racer who
lost both his legs in a horrific crash
I swear to God how the [ __ ] isn't one
one of the main articles it's not one of
the main articles you hype well I guess
when you got those kind of tits in the
and the Mac there he is
there he is if you want to read an
inspirational article this guy uh I hope
I say his name right uh Alex
is a Nardi I hope I said it right right
you know I'm not you know I'm not in the
Illuminati okay so I don't know much
about formula one [ __ ] racing
uh and I also live in the United States
so you know I watch stock car
I'm actually watching stock car now for
the [ __ ] fights there's barely any
fights anymore in the NHL
all you got to do is just you know if
you're really into fighting and you miss
it in the NHL just watch the last three
laps of an of a NASCAR
NASCAR rate his race it's [ __ ] great
because they don't have because it's
fighting is still so new to their sport
like you know hockey has been going on
since the beginning and new I mean a lot
over the last 10 years it's really
gotten out of hand
there's still no rules like you know
first guy over the walls an automatic 10
game I guess it would be 10 Race
suspension they don't have any of that
[ __ ] so entire pit Crews can fight other
pit Crews they have like a ballroom
brawl right out on there it's fits
phenomenal
so anyways this guy Alex Zanardi uh I
hope I'm saying it right no disrespect
to this guy
um he obviously is more of a [ __ ] man
than I'll ever be 2001 he had a horrific
car crash that nearly cost the champion
race car driver his life
um he spun out on Pit Row and somebody
came by going full speed and just
clipped off the front of his car and
took off both of his legs from the
bottom uh just below his knees
and this guy has since become he races
bicycles and like uh
he got back behind the wheel of a car
raced a little bit but now he got into
bike racing and he competes in marathons
uh the disabled uh part of it and he's
like the best in the world at it and he
has achieved so much
that um
he actually said that if he could go
back in life
and
go back to that moment of when he lost
his legs he'd actually have to sit down
and decide
you know whether I want not he'd want to
avoid it again because he learned so
much about life it's and I know that
sounds like some corny horseshit like
obviously you'd want your legs but after
reading this article you totally
understand as much as you could because
you haven't gone through the uh the
experience what this guy means and he
also has this great thing about
you know when pushing yourself like your
dreams how to make your dreams come true
is to set goals and all that and he had
this thing he used to call the five
second rule
and the five second rule is when you
thought you were at exhaustion and you
couldn't go anymore you just hung in
there for another five seconds and the
thought process was who knows maybe in
that five seconds the other guy would
quit and then he laughed after saying
that I thought that was so [ __ ] cool
so um anyways uh check that out it's
it's the Maxim magazine
um it says uh Hot Wheels and there's a
jaguar or white car on the cover with
this absolutely stunning woman who uh
you know in a perfect world owns the car
and just felt like sunning herself on
the hood
um anyways let's plow ahead here uh
effeminate straight man
all right
good morning how you doing how are you
all right he's got my lines done he said
me and my husband love the podcast
thanks for making my Monday morning a
little brighter just wanted to share
with you that in the last week my
husband has made pumpkin cookies pumpkin
pancakes and pumpkin pie from scratch
I have a fellow Twinkle Toes there hey I
tip my apron to you
um he said yeah she says he is also a
stay-at-home dad who drives the
uh a v e o I don't know I'm not familiar
with that Avail a veal I don't know well
I drive the Tacoma
on top of that he doesn't get offended
when I call him a [ __ ] when I come home
from work and I see him baking I believe
that is a slight one-up he also has a
thick beard
and not only watches hockey but Place
pickup games every Friday most
effeminate straight man I know go Ducks
and go [ __ ] yourself
well he didn't really ask me uh
you really didn't ask me any question
you know what it is he's got a beard and
he plays hockey you know what he's
already more of a [ __ ] man than most
of us so he's got to balance it out he's
got to bring that testosterone down he
comes home he bakes a couple cookies
he makes some pumpkin pancakes and you
come down you know you call him a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it makes you feel like
you're [ __ ] doing something
and the whole relationship works
I don't think that's an effeminate
straight man I think that's a [ __ ]
straight man who's comfortable with who
he is
who uh you know
what do you want you want me to go top
shelf you want me to put some uh [ __ ]
cookies on the table I can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want go [ __ ] yourself I
have a beard and I know how to do [ __ ]
um all right turning into a douche after
being dumped oh you never want to do
that
when you do that then they know that
they want
what you gotta do
is you got to take the feeling you got
to push it down and you got to bury it
all right and then you let it out slowly
after six drinks onto unsuspecting
strangers that's how you do it no that's
not what you do
what you do is reality what most men
what you should do after being dumped is
what you should do what Chris Bosh did
after they lost the championship that
year I think it was to the Mavericks he
just dropped to the floor and he cried
it out of himself and everybody made fun
of that guy do you realize how [ __ ]
much more healthier men would be if we
could actually do that it would be
absolutely horrific for women to see and
as much as they say they want to see it
they don't want to see it
you know what I mean
W that that's like the the the male
equivalent of watching your wife change
your [ __ ] tire you don't want to see
that
just seeing her out there jacking up the
car knowing what the [ __ ] she's doing or
maybe making a strong throw from third
base that's just some things that men
and women you think you want to see it
you don't want to see it
what if she grunt a little bit when she
throw just [ __ ] threw a laser right
ball takes a funny hop and she's still
able to [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's wrong
but there's just certain things it's
just that just you know drives them up
and sends us [ __ ] you know
pitching to the right of the left there
oh [ __ ] stand it's down for the count
if you know what I mean all right dear
Billy boy
um I actually should say yawing to the
left if I'm gonna go Aviation here uh I
am a 28 year old dude the beginning of
the year was Life kicking me in the nuts
my girlfriend been together for 10 years
left me for some rich older [ __ ] oh man
well if you want to feel better about
yourself just listen to the Eagles Lying
Eyes
you know because that's what the [ __ ]
she just walked into
unless he's only a few years older
um but if he's a lot older I mean what
the [ __ ] come on man
what kind of young woman wants some
guy's dick coming out with their [ __ ]
salt and pepper pubes I mean that's no
woman lays in bed dreaming about that I
can tell you that right now all right
needle needle needles needless to say
he wrote needles uh needless to say but
I will it got me absolutely heartbroken
depressed as [ __ ] feeling that I lost
all my goals in life had to leave our
apartment which I renovated for us to
finally be our No Place Like Home Place
had to move for a while back in with my
parents
that's always a hard time started hating
my job
yeah dude that's awesome dude what you
got what you got going on here is you
have a new beginning
all right you gotta understand the kind
of person
that would leave you to go get with some
rich older guy
I mean I don't know anything about your
relationship I mean it seems like you
had a job you renovated the apartment
you do seem like a motivated guy if you
want to think if you're sitting around
in your ass
look if you're sitting around your ass
you're not doing anything you just you
cannot expect a woman to stay with you
you're [ __ ] useless
as a man if you're not providing what
are you doing
you you're just a big kid
they don't need that
you're 180 pounds of [ __ ] excess
weight just dragging them down to the
ground they got one life they're gonna
go [ __ ] live it so
but you have a job you renovated the
place you sound like a good guy granted
you're right in the email here we go if
it wasn't for uh for the best friends
in the [ __ ] world I don't know what I
uh I do so it's been like eight months
got my [ __ ] together lost weight started
learning a new language here you go
started studying giving lectures and
clubs and banging a Hot Smart 22 year
old girl
and that banging is the [ __ ] he's saying
here look at this guy turned his life
around
uh you know and I can tell you all your
friends wish that they got dumped at
this point seeing you all of a sudden
walking around like you're the new
Johnny Bravo there but the shitty
thoughts about the X still stir in my
head well it's natural man you you were
together for 10 years
eight months later you know one 22 year
old in a new [ __ ] uh language you
still you know that's normal
he goes I feel bad because all that crap
lands on this new girl
oh dude that's that's the first wrong
thing you've done 10 years of sharing
experience is kind of hard to forget and
it always pops up I'm smart and
sensitive enough to know uh what I'm
doing is wrong well there you go look at
this you're an evolved guy
um he says although something inside
says do the [ __ ] is wrong with you you
should never say that to her never
compare her to the X yeah don't do that
never demand something she can't deliver
but somehow I still do it to the new
girl and it hurts her how do I get to
stop being induced to this chick well
Step One is you're admitting it and how
about this there's a huge difference
between 22 and 28 and a level of
maturity
32 to 38 there's nothing much different
but 22 to 28 you basically go from being
a kid to being an adult
um even though legally you're considered
an adult that's a um
that's a huge difference you know
I mean if you're 28 years old you go out
on a date with somebody and you go
what's your major that should be the
beginning of when it starts feeling
creepy
you know it's I don't know I always did
I was just kind of like oh my God this
person's still in [ __ ] College
you have a teacher and a semester
you know what the [ __ ] I mean just you
can't even relate to it
um
so how do you stop being induced to this
chick uh I would actually sit down with
her first off and I would apologize for
doing it
um that's the first thing you need to do
and get it out in the open and just say
that you know I'm gonna really work hard
to not do it and please call me out when
I'm doing it and I'm gonna do my best to
immediately stop it just know that uh
I'm coming down from a 10-year dump here
and I gotta it's gonna take me a little
bit so if you can be patient with me but
the last thing I want to do is hurt you
and this is not fair to you
um that that's the first thing I would
do yeah I would get a flowers and I
would totally [ __ ] apologize
um and be on my [ __ ] best behavior
you know for a while man because that's
that's a it's a [ __ ] it's really a
horrible thing
to do to take out your life on somebody
else take out your childhood and other
people which I did for [ __ ] like
15 years you know it's bad remember that
was that [ __ ] show with that guy My
Name Is Earl
you know I could do that just with my
[ __ ] relationships with women this
was [ __ ] bad
um anyways all right so I'm not saying
I'm above you or anything like that all
right see that put myself right on your
level I've done the same [ __ ] thing
so um if I could go back in time that's
what I would have done if there was a
podcast that I could have written to but
I did I was in a vacuum I was living in
a podcastless world walking around from
my dick telling me what to do mixed with
my childhood was a bad recipe all right
um I've worked at one of the better
known law firms in Los Angeles for the
past decade to get right into it I've
been having sex with money my female Dan
Dan Dan Dan
you never [ __ ] somebody you work with
what was that from there about last
night Jim Belushi
all right uh all right he's got his dick
out at work everybody gee what could go
wrong
he's been banging her for about a year
now great so she's probably developed uh
feelings for you as women do unless
you've spaced out the [ __ ] from
Christmas party the Christmas party what
is it is it the Santa hat because I want
to know even gonna have that fight at
some point uh we both stall at our desks
until the rest of the office has gone
home for the day and then we [ __ ] like
Savages on the desk or in the break room
I can guarantee you everybody at work
knows you're [ __ ] Garen [ __ ] to
you
they can see it in your eyes we're all
animals we we can sense things the same
way I'm standing on stage and the crowd
can sense if I mean something or I don't
if I'm joking or if I'm not if I'm on
good mood or they can just sense it as
I'm walking to the microphone without
even even knowing that they have that
skill it's a survival thing left over
from caveman days the same way a crowd
can do that to me everybody at work
knows you're [ __ ]
um anyways
he says it's been great and I have no
complaints so here's the thing one day
about a month ago our boss came back
into the office and caught us mid-act
all right if he takes his dick out all
right and wants to join now that's
that's a [ __ ] situation because your
job's on the line
oh Jesus
see this is why you never take your dick
out at work
um
you'll [ __ ] her from behind while I get
her in the mouth
don't look at me when I come uh uh that
was gross sorry uh she told us to go
home
and that she'd be speaking with us
individually
the following day oh she told you guys
to go home that's a power move
this is where it takes a twist
when I ended when I went in to talk with
my boss I was certain I'd be fired
however she oh no
no
she closed the blinds locked the door
hiked up her skirt to reveal she wasn't
wearing underwear and told me to perform
oral sex on her
what
dude is this a red shoe diary I I'm
calling [ __ ]
I don't know but how do you stop this is
like a good summer it's a good summer
read everybody you know let's let's all
mentally go to the beach right now like
a [ __ ] soccer mom here I assumed I
was being blackmailed but didn't care
because I need my job and I like [ __ ]
dude are you like a [ __ ]
caveman what is wrong with you so it was
a win-win
let me read back is the boss in there
I'm confused as to whether the boss is
in there or not when I walked went in to
talk with my boss I would certainly be
fired however she closed the blinds
locked the door
all right I guess I have to keep reading
here
the thing is
she didn't stop she calls me to office
at least twice a week to go down on her
for an hour
she says she has security footage of my
co-worker and I having sex
oh wait a minute
I miss that your boss is a woman
oh see the sexist me
assumed you had a male boss there you go
there you go I got work to do on myself
is another thing
wait a minute you got to go down on your
boss
she says she has security footage of my
co-worker and I having sex in the office
dude this is a crime
and that she'll fire us both unless I
continue to service her
so she's got to be old and hard up
dude this is a [ __ ] nightmare
what's worse to this can't be true you
made this up [ __ ] you
trying to get me during the holiday
season
I can't oh my God I can't stop reading
this what's worse is that my co-worker
doesn't know why she hasn't been fired
yet and I'm afraid to tell her about the
deal I have with our boss
ow Jesus Christ dude this is like a bad
movie if this is actually real you
[ __ ] tell her and then you film her
in the [ __ ] act with you
your boss right and then you say listen
unless you give us both a [ __ ] raise
we'll [ __ ] we'll rat you up
actually no what you want to do is go to
the cops because then you know because
then you're both doing it to each other
and then you like somehow the state
could maybe send you all to jail
anyways he goes I realize this isn't the
worst problem to have then you know what
dude I don't have a [ __ ] ing problem I
I my boss isn't exactly unattractive but
not someone I'd Approach at a bar or
anything think Jody Foster in Silence of
the Lambs so what do I do should I call
her Bluff and refuse to continue or
should I suck it up no pun intended and
keep on going also I should tell or
should I tell my co-worker and risk
ruining the relationship or Worse risk
getting the word out that I'm basically
a [ __ ] any help is appreciated thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself
uh or come [ __ ] my boss with me yeah
this guy's a jerk-off you don't give a
[ __ ] all right look at whenever you get
tired of being a man [ __ ]
this is what you need to do you need to
go Mickey Rourke here Pope a Greenwich
Village
you know
you got to get a tape
you got to come in there wired this is a
great thing since you're not [ __ ] her
you can come in there wearing a goddamn
wire and all you got to do is just have
her say some incriminating [ __ ]
all right and then you get to walk in
there
you know
and then you just you grab it by your
hand like and because I gotta [ __ ]
take tape I took off a dead cop right
you give her that [ __ ] speech you go
out you get your hair cut as you're
smoking a cigarette while some woman
[ __ ] manicures your nails and you
come walking in there Mickey Rourke Pope
at Greenwich Village
and you tell the [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
put you in jail you give me a raise
although I shouldn't you shouldn't do
that because now you've engaged in
criminal activity
what you need to do is you got to have
some [ __ ] self-esteem
you know what I would do honestly
because if
I personally I wouldn't want any of this
to come out
um what I would do
is I would get another [ __ ] job
and then I would just I would walk away
I would I think I would just walk away
isn't that funny this is the type of
[ __ ] thing that if a man was doing it
to a woman it'd be like oh my God this
saves the stop but I guarantee you most
of the women that listen to this thought
this this was a funny [ __ ] story
um
I guess it is it's just because they
can't physically [ __ ] Don like
this is the way the fact I don't know I
guess it's that thing that whole [ __ ]
thing that you could literally force
yourself on but she's literally forcing
you what a [ __ ] animal like I I still
don't believe that that's true
but I enjoyed it nonetheless
um
underrated
uh there are song lyrics and the ACT
what there are these are song lyrics and
the ACT is what is underrated
uh just before doggy styling a woman to
go Hut one Hut two
what
I hate when guys do [ __ ] like that like
I never found any of those [ __ ] jokes
funny
you know like this is the dirty sanchez
where you [ __ ] sticky
up top
you know that stupid frat boy [ __ ]
humor
um I always all of that [ __ ] always
comes from a place of insecurity that
like look it's so easy for me to get
laid that I can disrespect women in this
[ __ ] way you know what I mean
those are those jackhammering guys they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
in bed they just get on top
those [ __ ] guys those poor [ __ ]
women got to put up with that [ __ ] just
someone who just was not blessed with
any sort of [ __ ] empathy wasn't
blessed with any sort of uh [ __ ] and
no gift of touch or anything like that
those are those are those dirty sanchez
[ __ ] guy I always hated those [ __ ]
jokes yeah the donkey punch
you in the back is you really is that
what you do
does that make you a man you [ __ ]
jerk off all right anyways that's the
podcast for this week
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
sponsored by betmgm with your host Paul
Bursey Bill Byrne our wonderful producer
Andrew stemless and today we will
preview
going into week number 10 which I guess
is technically week nine because of the
buy but we are going to do week 10 games
uh last week yours truly finally had a
decent week I went 3-0 and one bill went
one two and one because he's Mr push the
kid just the kids just right on the spot
bill you like Vegas bill you like Vegas
I'm not like Vegas Vegas keeps picking
the perfect spread you know Paul when we
do anything better I I got a nice
[ __ ] rant for that goddamn prevent
defense which is [ __ ] me out of like
three wins this year
um well speaking of wins this year you
have a uh a lead here and you have week
uh you have week 10 first pick bill so
where are you going all right you know
what I'm riding that Seattle Seahawk
defense right into Tampa Bay
the king and the titty bars flown up
against Tampa Bay Buccaneers the
Buccaneers are just uh
you know I watched them last week Paul I
watched him the offense scored three
points in the first half
and they are you looking down no no I'm
listening
three points in the first half and they
scored three points in the second half
but thankfully the Rams went into the
prevent before the half and before the
end of the game and gave him [ __ ] 10
points they scored six points when the
Rams were playing defense Seattle's got
the best defense in the [ __ ] League
they're getting three points it's Pete
Carroll he's a better Coach than
whatever [ __ ] talking head they got
on Tampa Bay right now then nobody's
protecting Brady they're running game
all their [ __ ] wide receivers are
injured I don't know why it's only three
but I'm I'm you know what I'm jumping on
that hook Paul and Vegas is pulling me
in
all right all right I'm pissed Paul I'm
pissed about the [ __ ] prevent defense
I don't like being under 500 against the
[ __ ] bookie
[ __ ] egg-headed [ __ ] with their
goddamn Analytics
I'm gonna take
I'm gonna take the Miami Dolphins at
home
against Brissette and the Browns I just
think Miami's just in a [ __ ] stride
they got Tyreek Hill they got waddle I
think Tua is playing great and uh and my
buddy Jim florentine's gonna be at the
he's going to be at the game with his
kid so I gotta no I'm gonna I'm I'm
gonna you know I'm Gonna Take Miami
Dolphins minus three and a half I don't
like the half a point I'm not gonna lie
but I think they should win that game I
think they're better so there you go
Miami Dolphins minus three and a half at
home
all right I'm going to take the Titans
minus three
uh in Denver
I just think they're I've been saying
this all year there's a really well
coached team and I think they got a good
defense and Denver is still not on the
same page with uh Reggie Watts under
Center
I love it the [ __ ] his name I always
forget his name
uh who
the quarterback for the Broncos
oh Russell Wilson Russell Wilson amazing
quarterback it's amazing like watching
him go from the [ __ ] Seattle Seahawks
to the Denver Broncos was like watching
Daniel Carr uh Ricardo go from driving
for Red Bull to that [ __ ] orange car
he's driving now it's just like you know
he could have the best car in the
[ __ ] driver in the world Paul
you know you stick them in a Ford Escort
where's he going
he's going to get around the [ __ ]
track anybody's getting a Mercedes and
driving well
um dude there's a couple of intriguing
ones here but
you know something dude I'm gonna be
honest I'm gonna be honest with you
I'm gonna go head to head with you I'm
gonna take the Tampa Bay Buccaneers to
beat Geno Smith in the [ __ ] Seahawks
I I think I think that Tampa's gonna
ride that win even though it was the
Rams backing up off of them I think that
uh Brady I saw Brady's little video
after the game I like that it's only
three points and I think his wide
receivers dropped enough [ __ ] passes
where they're not going to do that again
so I'll go head to head with you on that
one I'll take the I'll take the Bucks
all right now I'm gonna take the [ __ ]
commanders I don't even know who that is
what they're getting 11 points look at
you the Eagles like you know it's a
division rivalry game I'm finally gonna
pull the trigger division rival games
are always close until I bet him I'll
take the commanders their solid team
they're getting 11 points where the [ __ ]
the eagle only the eagles need to do is
win they don't give a [ __ ] Paul and I
watch this they're going to be up by
like 16 points at the end of the game
and then they're gonna go to a [ __ ]
pre-bent and they're gonna give the
[ __ ] commanders again damn touchdown
because the Eagles should beat him by 11
and they will
oh yes they will but then they're going
to go into the [ __ ] prevent and then
the [ __ ] commanders are going to
cover that's what's happening and I'm
rooting for the Eagles to go undefeated
I'm sick of all those [ __ ] dolphin
guys drinking champagne every year
rooting against the kids the Eagles
aren't going to go undefeated but I mean
and I'm not saying that because Paul
you're really going out or to live there
you have to duplicate what the Dolphins
did just to get out of the [ __ ]
regular season you got to go 20-0 now or
else yeah like why are they still
sipping champagne when the Patriots went
18-0
yeah what are they going to shoot we're
not as good as them because we had to
play [ __ ] literally 19 games yeah
what are they going to sip champagne
when they add 25 games to this season
hey we went 17-0 we were still
undefeated the [ __ ] out of here
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know something I don't know if I'm
gonna touch my New York Giants minus
five I know they're coming off a buy and
they're coming off a loss but I
I don't know dude
the bills are coming off a loss too
against it dude this is a tough week man
I'm gonna I know this sounds nuts
what Paul you hit your stride
I'm gonna take I can't believe I'm doing
this but they're they're just bad and
they're coming off the Cults are bad I'm
gonna take
the Las Vegas Raiders at home minus six
against a new coach which they just
named interim coach Jeff Saturday
they I mean the Cults are just bad
um the Cults are bad I'm gonna take the
Raiders minus six at home they got to
win that game by six or seven points
they I mean the Raiders are a pathetic
franchise and I'm taking the
Indianapolis Colts whoa
oh yeah the Colts are one of those
[ __ ] teams plus another one this is
another one Paul it's gonna be a close
[ __ ] game and whoever's winning is
going into the [ __ ] pre-bent they're
gonna give them some points they're
gonna give him some points Paul and
you're gonna take that nice [ __ ]
Yankee fitted and you're gonna throw it
against your [ __ ] dream board or
whatever the [ __ ] chicks have on the
wall
did you see the Jim irsay press
conference bill
no what is he blaming now uh no it was
fantastic uh he uh used some words and
correctly made up a word uh he was
talking about the the team and he said
you know he made up an investigation too
basically for the last uh
uh basically for the last 20 or 30 years
I don't remember when he starts in 2000
or whatever he said uh he said we've
been in the in the upper quartile of
winning his franchises
that's a quartile
four tiles
uh how many picks do we have left one
each one that was it hey you've got one
because bill just came in with uh the
Colts okay
so I have
I have Miami the Tampa Bay Bucks and the
Raiders and foreign
because we're going head-to-head on two
yeah and uh
I think for my fourth and final pick I'm
gonna take
dude that Rams Cardinals game is such a
[ __ ] line
I hate that I hate that whole [ __ ]
Division if you can figure out what
other than the Seahawks I don't know
what the [ __ ] the 49ers the Rams or or
the or the Cardinals are gonna do week
to week
I'm gonna take the Jacksonville Jaguars
getting nine and a half in Kansas City
I like that one too Paul they're gonna
go into the prevent
they're gonna kick the [ __ ] out of them
and then they're going to take the foot
off the gas they're going to give them a
couple of gifts and then that's gonna be
it that's my new thing Paul this just
keeps happening to me
when the numbers that big take the
points
these [ __ ] [ __ ] Paul they'll go
for it on Fourth and goal in first in
the first quarter they have the balls to
do that
because they can since their scapegoat
is Analytics
but then before halftime at the end of
the game they they [ __ ] like don't
let them get behind you oh great so give
up 80 yards in four [ __ ] plays and
give Tom Brady four [ __ ] shots at the
end zone and he gets a soft [ __ ] pass
interference call and you lose the game
and now one [ __ ] Reporter Goes the
[ __ ] why did you just keep playing
defense
you know we uh we had a lot of uh missed
opportunities
makes me sick Paul I know I know oh
you're hot about the prevent
dude I'll save it for the anything
better let's do it on anything better
all right so uh no but you know what
time it is Bill
oh
it's the Monday night special
with some money for you can we [ __ ] all
right well here we go Monday night well
you already picked you already picked
the commanders so I'll take those points
with you here's the thing I don't like
about our Monday night special this year
and I don't know how bet MGM is going to
take me saying this but we're the under
over is killing me here it's killing me
here the under over okay uh under over
commanders might even win this [ __ ]
game Paul because if the Eagles are
going to lose this year it's going to be
just some douchebag in their own [ __ ]
Division and always this always happens
they play them twice a year they know
each other no secrets between these two
and no love lost
are we going over 44 or under Bill
I'm gonna say over in Philadelphia
you're gonna say over I like the over
under on people getting arrested
six
um all right I like over let's take
we're gonna take the points guys we're
starting the game 11 nothing Bill we're
starting the game 11 nothing come on
commanders okay we're gonna do that
we're gonna take over 44 and what are we
gonna do Taylor heinecke to throw one
why not he's a backup he's on the road
he's playing [ __ ] great they've won
four out of five with them he's playing
with house money
he's playing with house money he's like
a kid on Christmas what other sports
cliche the whole world is expecting him
to lose and [ __ ] to bed in Philadelphia
Monday and I don't think he's gonna Bill
hey he's just out there having fun like
a kid playing pickup football out in the
street I mean who is he which is the
first I mean who is he who's he
what is he he's playing with house money
oh dude we got to talk about something
on anything better all right everybody
better let's do it all right everybody
that's been our picks make sure you
download the app it's very simple it's
very simple you put in uh as much as ten
dollars they'll match it up to a
thousand dollars in free bets guys use
bonus code Burr that's b-u-r-r and uh
have some fun Have Some Fun For Nothing
Paul we've picked 30 winners
ESPN is terrified to talk about
all right we're the 30 and 36 gamblers
that no Sports Network wants to play
and we're picking eight games a week by
the way we're picking eight games a week
and we're kind of right there we're kind
of right there and right there Paul you
want to know what's funny I was on real
quick this is part of this podcast
because it it it's relevant I was on um
I was on good morning football and not
only did I call Russell Wilson the new
Ellen because he doesn't give his
teammates his phone number and everybody
doesn't like him but but then I said uh
they go Paul you want to do this pickle
pick with us we go out on the street we
go on the street we're gonna give you a
microphone and you pick one game right
and uh they I go yeah I go I'm gonna
take the Patriots over the Colts and I
looked in the camera and and before I
looked in the camera I looked at Jason
McCourty who actually played cornerback
for you guys I go hey Jason dude is this
with the spread and do they all burst it
out laughing they go no dude we can't do
that on TV yeah
I go is this with the I go I'm taking
the patch but is it with the spread and
they were just like they're like no Paul
we don't this is like a morning
and then I said Patriots
um all right everybody buddy so there
you go there's your week there's your
Monday night special Taylor heinecke to
throw one over 44 and the Washington
commanders starting the game with 11.
there it is good luck to you download
the BET MGM app use bonus code uh Burr
you get up to a thousand dollars um and
all you got to do is put in as little as
10 and they will match your money take
care
and remember guys to bet you got to be
21 years of age or older to wager in
Arizona Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas
Michigan Mississippi New Jersey New York
Nevada Pennsylvania Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4700 for Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]